Ben worked with Fincher Affleck did and
I am for gonger yes and so I went down
and visited the set one day Fincher is
like has that Kubrick thing like he
can't unsee what he sees and so I sat
behind him one day while he was
directing and it was this scene where
Ben and Rosman Pike walk into this
bookstore and when the camera rolled
they call Background which is for the
the actually people in the bookstore and
then yeah so when he calls background
and then action a background actor walks
across the frame and the scene's about
to start but Fincher is already
monologue he's going who the [__] walks
like that now Ben and Rosman are on the
other side of this bookstore and they're
doing the scene but Fincher's just still
talking about this and I'm sitting here
going like oh my God they're definitely
going to do the scene again they get
through the whole scene they're acting
their hearts out but it doesn't matter
because the scene ended before it began
friendship was cut and he takes the
headphones off he's like I mean what the
[__] was that and he looks at me now I
know what he's talking about we're
sitting there and as we're talking a
makeup artist comes on and David goes I
mean that's how you walk I think for
people like that it's almost like a
curse you know because he can't unsee
what he sees and and that's the the
that's the genius right